las cosas en el universo no sólo se
mueven de un lado a otro sino que
también rotan y lo que haremos en este
vídeo será comenzar a pensar en la
rotación y el movimiento rotacional
mientras sigo rotando este objeto porque
me parece hipnótico la primera pregunta
que debemos hacernos es cómo podemos
comenzar a cuantificar esto medirlo y
describirlo para poder predecir su
comportamiento vamos a ver el concepto
de desplazamiento angular conocemos el
desplazamiento que es el cambio en la
posición pero qué tal si tenemos también
un cambio en el ángulo creo que con esto
podríamos comenzar a describir la
rotación aquí mi ángulo es de 0 radiales
si muevo esto en sentido antihorario mi
ángulo ahora será pi entre 2 así pues
por qué no definir el desplazamiento
desde acá hasta acá como un
desplazamiento angular de pi entre dos
radiales si se desplaza a otros pi entre
dos radiales llegaría a esta posición y
si se moviera pi radian es negativos
llegaría a esta posición si se moviera
pi entre dos radiales
negativos llegaría aquí esto parece algo
bastante intuitivo y quizás se pregunten
por qué el sentido antihorario se toma
como positivo y por qué es negativo el
sentido horario es simplemente una
convención que se tiene para indicar la
dirección de los ángulos con esto ya
tenemos las bases para describir el
movimiento rotacional ya tenemos una
idea del desplazamiento angular que
podemos definir de una manera más formal
tal como lo describimos es el cambio en
el ángulo usamos la letra griega delta
para indicar el cambio en algo y usamos
la letra griega theta para indicar
ángulo estos símbolos los hemos usado
desde las clases de geometría y
trigonometría podemos definir nuestro
desplazamiento angular como el ángulo
final menos el ángulo inicial podemos
decir que esta es una cantidad vectorial
porque podemos movernos en sentido
antihorario que indicamos como una
cantidad positiva o en sentido horario
que indicamos como una cantidad negativa
hasta aquí todo va bien pero seguramente
alguno
ustedes está pensando que aunque está
bien saber cuánto ha cambiado nuestro
ángulo no sería más interesante poder
describir qué tan rápido está cambiando
por ejemplo aquí el ángulo cambia
lentamente
digamos que tarda tres segundos el tener
un desplazamiento angular de dos pi un
segundo dos segundos tres segundos esto
se siente mucho más despacio que si hago
el mismo movimiento en un segundo en un
segundo dos segundos sería bueno tener
algo que describa la tasa de cambio del
ángulo podemos tomar prestada cierta
terminología que hemos usado con
anterioridad en lugar de llamar a esto
velocidad vamos a llamar la velocidad
angular como describiríamos la velocidad
angular pausa en el vídeo y piensen en
ello podemos definir nuestra velocidad
angular como el cambio del ángulo en
cierta cantidad de tiempo si el cambio
en el ángulo es de 2 pirra dian es en un
segundo será más lento que si cambio el
ángulo 2 pirra dianas en medio
y la letra que se usa por convención
para la velocidad angular es la letra
griega o mega minúscula que luce como
una doble o minúscula que también es una
cantidad vectorial porque mide el cambio
de otra cantidad vectorial repasemos
esto para no olvidarlo el desplazamiento
angular es el cambio en el ángulo si el
cambio en el ángulo es en sentido
antihorario entonces será una cantidad
positiva si nuestro desplazamiento
angular comienza aquí aunque no siempre
comenzaremos en cero radiales
digamos que comenzamos en pie entre dos
y nos desplazamos pie entre cuatro
llegaremos a esta posición un
desplazamiento angular a partir de aquí
de menos pi entre dos nos llevará a esta
otra posición y si nos interesa la
velocidad angular si decimos que esto se
mueve irradian es cada segundo se verá
algo así un segundo dos segundos tres
segundos cuatro segundos si decimos que
se mueve dos pi radiales por segundo se
moverá el doble de rápido
términos de la velocidad angular en un
segundo dos segundos tres segundos
cuatro segundos cinco segundos en los
próximos vídeos nos familiarizar hemos
aún más con estos conceptos y veremos lo
poderosos que son para describir el
movimiento rotacional en el universo nos
vemos en otro vídeo